- What, are you recreating
the Sistine Chapel
in this boy's room?
- Not bad, right?
- You should be knee deep
in that sofa in there
with some Graeter's Ice Cream.
(laughing)
Don't move.
(grunts in pain)
(beeping)
Baby, where are you?
- [Kidnapper] Hello Paul.
- What do you want?
(car indicator clicking)
(police sirens)
- [Kidnapper] Last night a man
was taken to your hospital.
I need you to get him out.
- Wherever he goes, I go.
- Whatever you say, officer.
(intense music)
(beeping)
- What's happening?
- His heart.
Get me the defibrillator!
(shock)
(upbeat, intriguing music)
- You don't want to get
involved in this hole.
Let me handle it.
- Who took my wife?
- Dirty cops.
(loading guns)
- Where are you going?
- I'm going to kill 'em.
All of them.
♪ Good cop, good cop,
rollin' with that bad cop ♪
- Cops want you dead, homie.
(gun shots)
(car revs)
♪ Come after cuffs yeah ♪
♪ Knock off the rust ♪
♪ Throw my hands up,
you still wanna bust ♪
♪ The Trojan horse, is full ♪
- [Criminal] Lose the tail.
- This some real Grand Theft Auto shit.
- The fuck is that?
- It's a video game.
- I'm a fucking grown-up, man.
I don't play video games.
- Yeah, well maybe you should try
to help you with your aggression.
- Everybody's always saying,
"I'll do anything for my family."
This is as fucking anything as it gets.
- Bring him to us and
you'll get your wife back.
You got an hour.
(gun shot)
- You're going to jail.
- You just day stupid shit all the time.
If I'm going to jail
you're coming with me, pal.
(fighting)
♪ You know that mean
cop might need a detox ♪
♪ Motherfucker' tryna
blow me out my Reebox ♪
♪ But I swing like Jack
and the Beanstalk ♪
- I want it buffed and
polished, and the rims detailed.
- Can you get the fuck
out of the car please?
- I have pepper spray in my purse.
- I have a gun in my pants.
- What kind of fucking car wash is this?
♪ Bad cop, where's your humanity? ♪
♪ Good cop, is that just a fantasy? ♪